Y'all listen to this.
>> I got booked for a photo shoot. They
took me all the way up this mountain.
They having OD cars, three-seater
McLaren, they got a Ferrari. I'm asking
them like, "How y'all get all this
money? How y'all do this?" Like, they
like, "We do demonic rituals." I'm
laughing. No, you don't, bro. Like, how
you get this money though? Put me on.
I'm trying to get like y'all. So, what
type of demonic ritual? They say
Illuminati never talked to you. No, for
real. Leonardo DiCaprio do all the
initiation. He giving me a a list of
people who all did it. I'm going to keep
it PG-13. Either you let them peg you or
you do oral and you'll get whatever you
want. Tell them what you want. If you
want to be the next big actress, next
big whoever, I can take you to somebody
and all you got to let them do is just
do what they want to do to you before a
night. Do some gay basically do some
gay. I'm like hell man. You playing this
when they get to laughing. They like
they like oh we need to take him to the
booty club. Stop playing with me, bro.
He like bro I can make it happen. I'm
trying to call my Uber. We on top of the
mountain though. I don't got no service.
The people who booked me, they take off.
They was like, "Man, your flight didn't
take off anyway. Let us just get you a
hotel." So, I'm telling them, take me
down to the bottom of the mountain. The
way down, we take a right. So, he not
going the same way that we came up. He
said, "We not going to take you get no,
we spent all this money to get you up
here." It's face change, gang. In front
of me, you see Venom OD like long like
veins OD long his face. It was probably
about this wide face change. I'm like,
you'll see somebody morph into
something. It threw me all the way off.
So, I'm confused now. I'm like, "Okay."
I didn't know how to get out the car. I
would have been got out the car. It's a
mailman come out of nowhere, bro. Just
let me get in the back of your truck.
All right. Please just take me down.
Take me down to the bottom. Please just
take me down to the bottom. It God, he
took me down to the bottom. As soon as I
got up to the top of that mountain, it
it was something off.
>> Something wrong. Yeah.
>> Yeah. For me to actually see that in my
face, that's what like made me know that
the devil and God was real.
>> Look, how many Hollywood insiders have
to come out and say, "Look, I sold my
soul to the devil." like Kanye West or
lap dance on the devil like Lil NasX for
us to take this seriously and not say,
"Oh, it's just a metaphor. It's just for
shock value." People are coming out like
Project Pat. He says, "Look, I was doing
the devil's work." Former 36 mafia
member Koopa Nika said, "I made black
people comfortable with 666 and we
Christians just want to keep making
excuses to keep indulging in this
demonic music like a dog returning to
his vomit." And this is not some
conspiracy theory. Go back to when Jesus
was in the wilderness and Satan said,
"I'll give you all the kingdoms of the
world. Just bow down to me." You think
he stopped right there with Jesus? No.
He's still offering that offer today.
And there's so many people that would be
willing to take a deal like that to live
like God's on earth. But the Bible says,
"What profits a man to gain the whole
world and lose his very soul?" There's
nothing more valuable than eternal life
in the perfect kingdom with Jesus. And I
believe he's coming soon. It's time for
us Christians to wake up and stop making
excuses to play around in the devil's
playground and get our relationship with
Jesus closer than ever before.